thanks to brilliant for helping support
this episode hey crazies there are a lot
of stars in the universe somewhere
around ten to the twenty four that's a 1
followed by 24 zeroes I'm not even gonna
try to make sense of that it's big and
those stars come in all the basic colors
except green and purple this episode was
made possible by generous supporters on
patreon C a star's color comes from one
of its outermost layers a layer called
the chromosphere or color sphere because
you know signs names the light emitted
from that chromosphere is based on its
temperature which means we can tell a
star's surface temperature just by its
color how cool is that red stars are the
coolest and blue stars are the hottest I
know that's backward from the labels you
see on sink handles and stuff those
colors are thermodynamically inaccurate
where was I again right stars in
temperature order they go from red to
blue but where we'd expect to have a
green star we have a white star instead
why though
statistical mechanics an object's
temperature comes from the wiggling and
jiggling of its little particles in fact
we relate the temperature directly to
the kinetic energy of those particles
that's the energy of their motion their
wiggling and jiggling as the particles
jiggle around they bump into each other
and lose some of that energy which is
carried away as light but each particle
is jiggling a different amount this is
only the average kinetic energy of the
particles the actual kinetic energy of
any given particle is probably not that
number what did you expect the universe
to be simple when they bump into each
other different particles will lose
different amounts of energy and
therefore release different light
statistically the distribution looks
something like this we call it a
blackbody curve this is what the curve
looks like for the Sun and it matches up
pretty well with experimental data
but we can't actually see all that light
we only see a tiny fraction of it what
we call visible light because you know
science names they're boring but
descriptive seriously though the scale
on this graphic isn't linear it's a
logarithmic scale some people call it an
exponential scale but don't get me
started on another rant on a chart that
goes from a trillionth of a meter up to
10 kilometers the visible range only
spans 300 nanometers if we were to
stretch the full spectrum between Los
Angeles and New York the visible part
would only be as wide is this single
piece of thread human eyes suck anyway
let's get back to that blackbody curve
we don't need the entire curve to
understand color we only need the part
in the visible range we can't see the
rest anyway since multiple colors are
emitted simultaneously they'll mix
together and we have to worry about what
that's gonna look like to human eyes we
saw in a previous video how human vision
actually works our eyes have red blue
and green sensors that sends signals to
the brain our brain combines those
signals to interpret the entire visible
spectrum but it has an interpretation
for every possible signal it could
receive including signals that don't
correspond to a single wavelength of
light to truly understand color we need
a chromaticity graph this assigns a
color to every possible signal the human
brain could receive from the eyes
actually an RGB screen can't display all
those colors he's right I'm lying a
little bit mm-hmm technically an RGB
screen can only accurately display
colors inside this triangle outside that
triangle
it's faking it it's the best I can do
okay so chromaticity the outer curved
edge is all the colors that correspond
to a single wavelength of light what we
call monochromatic colors or single
color colors again boring name but
descriptive anyway that curve is the
entire visible spectrum from red all the
way up to violet or what you might call
purple there isn't much purple though
only a tiny bit at the very
and everything else on the chart is a
combination of multiple colors that's
where you'll find the rest of the purple
so let's see what happens with the light
coming from a star red stars aren't too
complicated
almost all the light is red so the star
appears red as we look at hotter stars
the color shifts as we'd expect orange
and then yellow but something weird
happens when the peak shifts to green
even though it's peaking in green there
are a lot of other colors coming from
that star there might be more green than
anything else but there's a significant
amount of all visible wavelengths
there's also a roughly equal amount
coming from the blue side as there is
coming from the red side the
monochromatic colors are mixing together
back to the chromaticity graph star
colors aren't along the monochromatic
curve they're along this curve we call
it color temperature you'll find the
coolest stars in the red corner I'm
ready ouch oh no I didn't mean that kind
of red corner it's been forever since
I've been in the ring I know I'm sorry
I'll find a use for you soon I promise
spoopy in okay so the coolest stars are
in the red spot they're nearly
monochromatic as we look at hotter stars
we get orange and yellow but they're not
monochromatic orange and yellow color
mixing gradually gets more extreme by
the time we expect to see green there
are so many other colors around that the
star looks white instead all colors
mixed together and roughly equal amounts
looks like white to us so we don't get
any green stars we get white ones like
our Sun yes the Sun is white this
balance between the colors disappears
when we look at even hotter stars as the
temperature goes up the peak continues
moving to the left that means more blue
light and less red light will be emitted
from the star if the star is hot enough
that imbalance will be large enough for
the star to look blue so how hot for a
purple star never gonna happen
seriously never that blackbody curve
might be shifting to the left but it's
also going up
it might be peeking in ultraviolet or
x-rays or something but there's still a
lot of visible light and that intense
mix of colors keeps the star blue no
matter what the surface temperature is
the color temperature on the
chromaticity graph dead ends in blue
I mean stars don't get anywhere near
infinite surface temperature the hottest
stars only get up to about 200,000
Kelvin but you get the point so why
aren't there green or purple stars
because color is more complicated than
the visible spectrum stars emit multiple
wavelengths of light at the same time
when colors mix we have to consider how
all those signals are going to be
interpreted by the human brain stars
emit light based on their surface
temperature which only generates colors
along this curve green and purple aren't
on that curve so how cool would it be to
see green and purple stars anyway let us
know in the comments thanks for liking
and sharing this video don't forget to
subscribe if you'd like to keep up with
us and until next time remember it's
okay to be a little crazy
brilliant mission is to help people
achieve their learning goals so whether
you're a student or professional
brushing up or learning cutting-edge
topics or someone who just wants to
understand the world better you should
check out brilliant they make that easy
with interactive explorations and a
mobile app that you can use on the go in
their new course programming with Python
you can actually test your code right in
the browser with brilliant premium you
can learn something new every day if you
like this video you might like their
course on astronomy it has quizzes on
how we explore the universe using light
brilliant helps you achieve your goals
in stem one small commitment to learning
at a time if this sounds like a service
you'd like to use go to brilliant org
slash science asylum today the first 200
subscribers will get 20% off an annual
subscription so why is the Martian sky
red technically Mars the sky isn't red
it's it's pink the Martian atmosphere is
95 percent carbon dioxide and filled
with iron oxide dust so it's the same
explanation is Earth's blue sky it just
has a different composition anyway
thanks for watching
you